a club of nine people wants to choose a
board of three officers president vice
president and secretary assuming the
officers are chosen at random what is
the probability that the officers are
marcia for president sabitha for vice
president and robert for secretary so to
think about the probability the
probability of
marcia
so let me write this president
president is equal to marcia
or vice president is equal to savita
savita and secretary
is equal to robert
robert this is going to be this right
here is one possible outcome one
specific outcome so it's one
outcome out of the total number of
outcomes over the total
number
of possibilities
total number of possibilities now what
is the total number of possibilities
well to think about that let's just
think about the three positions
let's just think about the three
positions you have president you have
vice president and you have secretary
now let's just assume that we're going
to fill the slot of president first we
don't have to do president first but
we're just going to pick here so if
we're just picking president first we
haven't assigned anyone to any officers
just yet so we have nine people to
choose from from so there are nine
possibilities here
now when we go to selecting our vice
president we would have already assigned
one person to the president
so we only have eight people to pick
from and when we assign our secretary we
would have already assigned our
president and vice president so we're
only going to have seven people to pick
from so the total permutations here or
the total number of possibilities or the
total number of ways to pick president
vice president secretary from nine
people is going to be 9 times 8 times 7
which is let's see 9 times 8 is 72 72
times 7 2 times 7 is 14 7 times 7 is 49
plus 1 is 50. so there's 504
possibilities
possibilities so to answer the question
the probability of marcia being
president savida being vice president
robert being secretary is one over the
total number of possibilities which is
one over
that's the probability